hi I'm Rob you I can't say my name Rob
Rob Huebel Rob Huebel rah pupil hi I'm
Rob Huebel from do you want to see a
dead body on YouTube read a show where I
make people very uncomfortable and now
I'm gonna make even more people
uncomfortable by asking them very
private questions won't you come along
[Music]
what was the last thing that made you
cry I saw this video of a starving polar
bear what's on your face right now is
not a tribute to that polar bear no I
was doing a one-person show and I got a
standing ovation oh the movie Coco were
you by yourself no with my husband so
how long did you cry to move it
not that long like a couple minutes
minute INGOs the movie pirates can't
believe you look like you could be a boy
coworkers
what happened they're jealous of you how
much money did you make last year
alright taxable income or
under-the-table altogether altogether
probably around 82 and how much of that
was under the table
around I really don't know I don't know
50,000 let's just go with that
maybe three four thousand I'd like to
stay private on that or actually doesn't
have cares no [ __ ] care we made a
hundred sixty-four thousand like what is
my rent and double that maybe so maybe
like three thousand a month
so three thousand a month times 12 is 36
yeah but so you're saying double that's
his seventy two thousand two thousand
dollars I'm a college student
none I was in high school other than my
mother do you want to say thank you
thank you mom to me oh thank you you're
asking the question what's something
that you would like to change about
yourself I think I could be more
outgoing and really just go for what I
want more often what do you mean you did
a one-person chef
they must have more fish well I don't
have three meals a day we should try to
get Zarek some food oh no I'm fine I'm
working on not caring so much about what
other people think of me like not
worrying about being polite yeah so be
rude yeah it's like compared to even
people who are like my height because
I'm losing my legs are really short I am
actually
going to stop drinking the first of the
year I'm not say forever but just take a
break I don't really want to change
anything about myself I think I'm good
you seem like a pretty fit guy you got
your hat on backwards so you can run
fast tell me about how you lost your
virginity that's private
I know that's the whole point yeah was
at home to your house or your parents
last Karen's like hey babe let's take a
nap so was he trying to take a real man
probably
I wasn't risky cuddles every time we
built a little fort and she says if you
bring me some animal cookies you can go
ahead I said wouldn't it goes I'm
friends uh do you were friends with yeah
before I'm there I still do the friends
are your friends
I didn't look I said I'm really busy
what would you like it to be like
perfect butts probably gonna be really
awkward and messy
I read Tina Fey's book and she was like
she's I think she said she was 24 25 so
I was getting to that age and I was like
all right let's just take care of this
the day before Valentine's Day so it was
special I didn't want to be cliche
this lady was dancing she might have had
some kind of form of sash the chemistry
was so powerful so it just was I mean
it's sad sad I mean yeah were you like
hey let's take a nap not really gonna be
better no it was not romantic in your
bedroom yeah parents of course not
where were they she's always working my
kids will have babysitters have you ever
cheated on someone no Jordan no haven't
you done anyone Jordan seriously the
only thing I've cheated on let's make it
a test or two but you didn't care you
got to quit anyway so technically you
cheated on him I guess no that is
actually a strong belief system I have I
feel one should be able to talk to the
person say this isn't working out we
should see other people aforementioned
first boyfriends he cheated on me right
actually went to go audition for a
production of hair back home and he
broke up with me on my layover and I
booked the show he's booked hair so f
that guy yes I just learned it with
other people
oh so you think flirting is cheating if
someone's complimenting you and you say
thank you then that's fine but if you
pop them at them back even if it's in a
friendly way that's still kind of
cheating be honest be honest I am I've
been cheated on by three people what
happens now
come on now come on now no I'm not a
cheater I want to be sometime you know
when people just get you mad you're just
like I just want to cheat on you tell me
about the one that got away she is all
my girlfriend with my wife now and
she moved to Hawaii like I'm actually
gonna go down to LA I picked her up at
LAX and then from there I we started
hanging out
well my first crush was Corbin Bleu from
high school musical how's he doing he's
married usually it's the other way
around we're you're the one that gets
away yeah so Delanie is the one that got
away she there's an anchorage admit her
where I was working at the resort at the
time why did you let her get away
I feel like I didn't deserve her I had
your shoes that one killed me it took me
three years to re-evaluate my soul if
you will he ended up dating my friend
and they had children he was a good guy
though you still see him around if I go
to church I've been in relationship now
for a couple of years so I'm definitely
over it does he have a girlfriend no he
doesn't ah ha you won we don't know so
she didn't get away this is her yeah
come over here and he said she didn't
get away I'm with her right now
you guys should kiss kick him in the
balls
we have a little surprise for you Dana
he's right here there is there is he
aged a lot that was slightly disturbing
also upsetting somewhat encouraging and
uplifting just like the internet I don't
[Music]